the power dynamics of the one-piece
world have just completely been flipped
on its head with the official release of
chapter
1053 we finally know how the government
has assessed the events that happened
during the raid on onigashima on wano
big news morgan and the gorosei have sat
down cranked the numbers and updated a
whole number of bounties for everyone
involved in that battle the three
captains luffy law and kit all have
received a massive increase to their
wanted posters each of them now sitting
at a staggering 3 billion barry bounty
which at first might seem a bit low
given that both big mom and kaido had
bounties well over 4 billion but
remember that blackbeard's bounty is
only 2.2 so in other words all three of
them just overtook the possibly most
dangerous pirates on the planet also it
of course follows the really nice
pattern of three that luffy has followed
throughout the story thirty three
hundred and now three billion berries
even if you expected just a bit more i
just want you to appreciate that luffy
and co now have the fourth highest known
bouncy in the entire story given that
kaido and big mom presumably don't have
a bounty anymore because they did fall
into a volcano and apparently well
that's just that so now we have three
members of the worst generation that was
looked upon as just a group of rookies
only two years earlier throning at the
peak of the one piece world and yet
somehow even more shockingly the gorosei
have also identified the two official
replacements for both kaido and big mom
for the title of the four most powerful
pirates in all of one piece the yonko
the last remaining member of the
original four now is shanks who with his
4 billion barry bounds he is now
officially the most wanted pirate in the
world probably only topped by the head
of the revolutionary army monkey d
dragon it's not really like we need any
more intrigue for shanks i think already
the one character in the story every
single fan including me is just dying to
learn more about finally but it
definitely helps to push the mystery i
guess and funnily enough all four kern
yonko either are shanks or have a
personal connection to shanks for some
reason the next in line is blackbeard
who has been an emperor since the marine
fort war and who tirelessly keeps
increasing his power and influence in
the new world blackbeard without any
doubt has been built up as one of the
major final antagonists if not the major
final antagonists that luffy will have
to face to actually reach his goal and
become pirate king we have seen
surprisingly little of his actual
abilities but just a little we know
about him and his crew is already enough
to let us know what an incredibly
powerful enemy he will be for luffy and
the other straw hats blackbeard did rise
into the ranks of the yonko after taking
out whitebeard at marineford and
literally taking his place
which is absolutely ironic and kind of
hilarious i think because that was
literally buggy's idea when he was
escaping impul down together with luffy
and the other level 6 prisoners as you
can see in this panel here he literally
talks about becoming an emperor and then
pirate king here like what and so for
some reason what seemed like a gag
moment for his character has now for
whatever reason actually turned out to
be true still trying to get over this
and honestly it will probably take a
while to get used to buggy the clown
being an emperor of the seas holy moly
however in retrospect when we look at
the great scheme of things it does truly
feel like ichiro oda the author of one
piece was working towards this for a
while now ever since impel down buggy
has been constantly getting more and
more influence and recognition by pure
accident really recruiting some of the
most powerful and notorious pirates to
his cause and even rising into the ranks
of the warlords now of course you could
joke that buggy might have been doing
all of this on purpose all along and it
wasn't luck at all and honestly at this
point i guess this is a real possibility
given the circumstances we don't really
know how he got into the position or how
high his bounty is now but there are a
ton of interesting possibilities i have
floating around my head and i will
definitely dedicate an entire video to
emperor buggy in the coming weeks so
make sure to subscribe if you want to
see that you'll also help me increase my
own bounty by 100 berries by subscribing
which is super important because we
might not know buggy's bounty yet but we
know that this slime ball here treble
has
99 million berries and i'm only at 60
million so let's go and beat treble
together the fourth emperor on the other
hand has a bounty so high now that i
will never be able to catch up in my
wildest dreams
luffy had unofficially been named the
fifth emperor of the sea by big news
morgan after escaping whole cake island
and defeating katakuri and now after not
only having beaten kaido the world's
strongest creature by the way but also
having awakened a mythical zone devil
fruit the world government has been
fearing for 800 years it's really no big
surprise that he's officially been named
yonko and thus has reached the last step
before becoming king of the pirates on
top of all this we have just witnessed
green greenball's terrifying abilities
who is said to be on the same level as
fujitora the marines clearly have made
up for the loss of aokiji and sengoku
recently and of course we still haven't
seen the result of the ssg the special
science group in case you forgot led by
dr vegapunk that the marines seem fairly
confident that it's able to replace the
former warlord system so it must be
truly terrifying indeed and so as a
result in the span of just a few weeks
in the story the entire world order has
been fundamentally
changed i mean it really used to be
relatively stable a balance between the
four emperors all careful not to mess
with each other the seven warlords who
were strong pirates aligned with the
government as well as the marines and
its admirals however over the course of
wano the warlord system has been
abolished two of the yonko have fallen
and been replaced and the revolutionary
army has successfully infiltrated the
holy land of marijua during the reverie
we have learned about a secret true
ruler of the world emu who controls the
entire world government we have seen
shanks talk to the gorosei and have
witnessed luffy's immensely powerful
awakening and the return of joy boy and
the drums of liberation now as we know
luffy's dream is to create a world where
all his friends can eat and drink as
much as they want and not only do i
share that sentiment but so does box
soup the sponsor of today's video i get
one of these every single month with me
and my housemates always look forward to
they contain original assortments of
premium japanese snacks and tea pairings
directly from japan to wherever you may
live every box has a unique theme and
since it's basically impossible right
now to go outside because it's so hot
the new baksu is adequately named
manatee which means mid summer there's
this great lemony sponge cake this
crunchy pineapple sweet or my personal
favorite this yuzu cookie which was made
in oita where i just went to visit dogen
and his new house everything in this box
is made in collaboration with
traditional japanese manufacturers which
i think you can really taste i know a
lot of you already have signed up but in
case you haven't and you want to try it
out for yourself go get your own box of
snack box and get 15 of your first order
using my kodohara and the link in the
description below and so i think it's
pretty fair to say that the one piece
worlds now and the one-piece world at
the beginning of the story are
fundamentally different indeed gone is
the stability of whitebeard's era the
government is building military force
like never before the revolutionaries
have begun to openly attack the
celestial dragons blackbeard has broken
all the rules of devil fruit use and
power balance and luffy who used to be
an upcoming small fry in a giant world
filled with powerful people is now one
of the handful of selected people in the
worlds powerful enough to shape the
future of the entire planet and all of
its inhabitants dude no wonder that one
piece is about to move into its final
saga if i look at it from this
perspective oh and now there's of course
also buggy the biggest wild card of them
all that now it seems will be playing a
much more central role during the ending
of one piece than we all originally
expected him to i think while it's
really easy to focus on luffy's growth
and don't get me wrong saying it was
rapid would be the understatement of the
century we should still not forget that
all other players in the endgame here
have been getting stronger and more
influential as well blackbeard just
keeps collecting more and more powerful
devil fruits and crew members shanks is
doing his super secret mission
impossible hidden plan behind the scenes
and the government and the marines seem
even more well equipped and all-powerful
than ever before really chapter 1053
also hinted at the reveal of pluton that
apparently is located in wano something
robin has known all along but somehow
decided not to share with the rest of us
thanks for nothing robin well whether
pluton will turn out to be an actual
weapon ship or whatever or simply
momonosuke the heir of the kazuki clan
similar to how you know hoshi is
poseidon once the ancient weapons
unleash their true powers they will just
add to the already overboiling pot of
fast approaching conflict brewing all
over the new world right now in a really
ironic way the new world order in one
piece doesn't really deserve its name
when you think about it because all
individuals involved blackbeard buggy
luffy kid law and even some people like
green ball they're all people who seem
to bring about the exact opposite of
order this entire new system is more a
world of chaos that is ready to be
fundamentally changed so that pirates
and marines and yonkos will not even be
a real thing anymore honestly i think
we've already entered the phase now
where luffy will be able to change the
world bring the dawn and create a place
where everyone is free to be who they
are and do what they want to do and just
you know live a happy and safe life
after all we now know that this is
luffy's actual dream becoming pirate
king so he can create this free world
for his friends we do not know however
what everyone else wants even when the
goro say i guess want to just stay in
power and buggy presumably still just
wants to find a massive pile of gold but
we don't know for example what
blackbeard really wants or shanks or
kids or many of the admirals heck we
don't even know what dragon's ultimate
goal is with the entire revolutionary
army so all of this really seems to be a
massive setup for some of the best
fights and meetings we have seen in all
of one piece so far the one i personally
look forward to the most is actually
that between luffy and blackbeard for
obvious reasons but there are a number
of other meetings that are basically
guaranteed to happen as well oda sensei
has actually come up with an ingenious
technique to foreshadow big battles and
unresolved conflict in the story in the
most unusual way ever by giving
characters their iconic scars so if you
want to find out what luffy and co scars
predict for the future of one piece you
should really watch this video right
here